[Music]
hi i'm dan fox one of the reporters from
nature here at cop26
now before the conference we asked you
what questions you would like to have
answered by one of the many experts here
in glasgow and a lot of you ask
questions about carbon capture questions
like this one what are the most
promising carbon capture technologies
currently in development
on their way to market and how effective
do you think these technologies will be
in combating global climate change
okay so i think we need to speak to
someone who has a really good overview
of carbon capture
[Music]
so i'm stuart hazeldean from the
university of edinburgh and i'm the
world's first professor of carbon
capture and storage well there are all
sorts of different ways of capturing
carbon dioxide and that's one of the
important things to realize is that our
society is really still using huge
quantities of hydrocarbon fuels whether
it's coal oil or gas and we use those in
different ways in industry in heating in
transport and in electricity generation
and carbon capture and storage can apply
across that range of opportunities and
use different capture methods for
different things
and even still developing now carbon
capture from the air will use again very
different capture media it could be
chemical solvents of different types it
could be membranes it could be adsorbing
carbon dioxide into porous molecules and
it could be quite simple domestic
compounds like potassium hydroxide can
also capture co2 and those different
applications for different purposes can
all be commercial and will all be and
are all being developed right now
the key thing we've got to try and do is
to make the energy of carbon capture
less and less and less because that's a
penalty in capturing carbon dioxide
many of the existing solvents have to be
heated to 120 150 centigrade and that's
a big energy penalty which needs
decreased so if we can design solvents
which just need heated to 80 centigrade
or 50 centigrade that'll be a huge
benefit
but already existing in other types of
capture is chilled ammonia is potassium
hydroxide which work at very low
temperatures with very low energy
penalties so
it's not a simple question so it's got a
complicated answer
so hopefully that gives you some idea of
where carbon capture technology is
headed
now we actually have a follow-up
question about how safe it is
should this technology prove to be
viable
bearing in mind the vast quantities of
carbon dioxide that would have to be
stored is this not tend to amount to
leaving our successors with an
environmental problem similar to but
possibly many times worse than than the
tanks of nuclear waste currently stored
at sellerfield
[Music]
yes i'm dr catherine romanek from the
university of texas at austin bureau
economic geology first of all as
geologists we know the right places to
store co2 we want to find a reservoir
that is porous that will accept the co2
and that needs to be overlain by layers
that are non-porous so that it is
trapped
in the reservoir there are additional
methods that trap co2 and those are
residual trapping within the grains of
the geological formation the the forces
trap the co2 there and then over time
the co2 will dissolve into the formation
water and then mineralize so we know
that over time the security of the site
increases
in addition we've been looking a lot at
environmental impacts of co2 storage if
it were to leak what would happen and
we've been very concerned about the
impacts onto groundwater so we have
taken many many scientific approaches to
trying to understand what the impacts
would be to underground potable sources
of drinking water and so we we know from
the results of all those studies that
if there's any impacts they are
localized and they are transient we know
that the main avenue of leakage would be
through a well so it would be like a
plumbing problem we just have to fix the
plumbing valve so we're feeling a lot
better about the safety and permanence
of storage because we put a lot of
science to that
you